good day everyone welcome I'm Jack
vanhorn from the University of Virginia
and I'm very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our 2023 2024
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series the lecture series is
supported by UVA integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA College of Arts and
Sciences the UVA School of data science
and through a grant from the National
Institutes of General Medical Sciences
since 2016 the foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series has put a
focus on the use of data science
methodologies artificial intelligence
deep learning and statistical modeling
as they pertain to differing themes in
the biomedical and Health Sciences our
theme this year is focused on building
Partnerships for generative AI training
in biomedical and clinical research
where each Friday we enjoy presentations
from a wide range of leading thought
leaders about the issues the promise
opportunities and hurdles which are
associated with the merging AI methods
applied to biomedical data science
biomedical science data types
participants for our biomedical data
science Innovation lab program leverage
seminars such as this as vital material
in our culminating inperson manuscript
and Grant project development Workshop
which will be held at the Bahia
beachfront Resort in Sunny San Diego
California in June of 2024 we are very
excited about this year's uh engaging
program we believe it's uh very unique
bringing together AI platform developers
biomedical researchers and University
level Educators to better understand the
power promise and potential pitfalls
associated with the generative AI
explosion today I am delighted to
welcome our speaker Dr Daniel Katz from
the national Center of supercomputing
applications uh he where he is a
research associate professor in computer
science and research associate professor
in electrical engineering uh as well as
in their um School of information
Sciences um Dan is um again a chief
scientist at the national Center for
supercomputing applications um his
interests include policy issues such as
citation and credit mechanisms and
practices associated with software and
data organization and Community
practices for collaboration and career
paths for computing researchers he is
co-founder and current associate
editor-in-chief of the Journal of open-
source software and co-founder of the US
research software engineering
Association and also a co-founder and
steering committee member of the
research software Alliance and in
continuing our 2023 2024 biomedical data
science seminar series theme Dan's
lecture today is entitled towards
sustainable research software through
software citation Fair research software
and research software engineer career
paths Dan is going to remind us that we
have a number of overlapping goals which
relate to science in particular um
seeking new knowledge for its own
purpose as well as its potential
solution both in detail and general
problems um this knowledge can be
captured in the forms of text images and
data and in his talk he will focus on
how that knowledge is captured um and
how it can both be read executed and
extended this often requires a human to
curate things um which ends up being an
integral part of that in terms of making
sure uh that there is uh some sense to
how how things are done this leads to a
number of overlapping challenges um and
corresponding efforts including making
research software findable accessible
interoperable and reusable which Dan
will tell us a lot about um and his talk
will highlight some of the recent
activities in these areas including fair
for research software principles
software citation um he'll discuss the
Journal of open- source software and
software career paths and as always we
are streaming this lecture live and for
recording via YouTube and if you're
watching on YouTube thank you so much
for joining us also our specially
selected 2023 2024 biomedical data
science Innovation lab participants and
alumni are encouraged to submit any
questions they have via the chat feature
um in their YouTube sessions I'll be
synthesizing these questions and asking
them on your behalf during the last 10
minutes or so of the lecture and with
that welcome Dan we are really looking
forward to your presentation thank you
so much for being here okay thank you
yeah it's a it's it's very nice to be
able to be here in this series that has
a very nice history and and lots of
interesting people that have been here
before me so it's it's great to follow
this um I should uh just to start off
with I will say that the uh all these
slides are published on zenodo and
there's a link on the bottom of each
slide that goes to there and so if
you're interested in following up in
anything there hopefully in in many
cases are links that you can click on in
the individual slides to get more
information so uh yeah so as Jack was
saying um I'm going to start off by by
the fact that I think that that most of
us as researchers and scientists are are
actually want to collaborate um and we
we do this under the name open science
and that's the free sharing of
scientific ideas methods and results um
it's not just science so open science as
a term is a little bit misleading uh
it's really more of this German uh
Vision shaft term that that means
knowledge and scholarship more broadly
not just within
science um this kind of collaboration
and sharing initially was done through
handwritten letters and books and was
mostly for other scientists and then we
got to the point where it was done more
frequently through printed journals and
that actually then also expanded the
audience uh and digitalization then
expands the opportunity for sharing even
further as well as what what can be
shared um and this then leads also into
democratization of research through
Public Funding and information sharing
through a bunch of different kinds of
platforms that then expand the the
community and at least the audience if
not the active
researchers um this has led us to the
idea of knowledge as a as a common good
a societal good and this term open
science it's interesting when I was
trying to to see actually where this
came from um the first place that I
could find it was in uh science in
1882 but here open science really had
the term had the had the sense of using
the scientific method it wasn't what we
would call open science today open
science in its modern sense seems really
to have started in the mid1
1980s um through a through a Trias
project as as far as I can tell but if
anybody thinks that this is incorrect
I'd be happy to to update my slides for
the
future um in addition to wanting to
share we also compete and we do that
because our lives are driven by
economics uh we live in a capitalistic
society and economics is really the
thing that's pushing our our lives and
our careers it determines where we work
you can think in terms of of hiring
practices uh how we support ourselves
and you can think about promotion
practices um how we actually get funding
to do our work which you could think of
in terms of support and recognition um
what questions we try to answer uh often
are based on where we think there's a
space that will be recognized for
answering those questions and what
students we train or or take advantage
of depending on your
Viewpoint um and so economics is the is
the science of allocating scarce
resources to maximize the achievement of
competing ends um and sometimes this
isn't really a true argument for us
because some resources can be increased
without worrying about what's competing
and an example of this is digital
resources like software or like
data um so so if we look at how we're
actually working it's some combination
of of competing and collaborating and if
we're trying to increase the
collaboration part we can think about
that is driving engagement um and so
engagement uh can be defined as
meaningful and valuable actions that
produce a measurable result um and and
this is really that we choose when and
where to come together to do something
collectively um a definition of
Engagement is is motivation plus support
minus friction and you can think of
motivation as having two parts intrinsic
motivation which are basically all the
things inside you um and extrinsic
motivation which are all the things kind
of outside of
you the support is is basically kind of
how how can you do these things more
easily in some sense um what what makes
the what makes you more likely to engage
and friction are the things that make
you less likely to engage the things
that are that are hurting your
engagement um I'll come back to this as
we go
forward so if we do think then about why
we don't actually collaborate if we have
this idea of open science but we don't
always do it why not um and some of the
reasons are that sharing takes effort
and and the immediate benefits of that
sharing actually go to others they don't
go to
yourself um often people are embarrassed
about the details um for example if
they're thinking about sharing their
software they may say well I didn't
really write the software very very
prettily it doesn't look very
professional um they may not want to
support others that are going to be
using the things that they've shared
right I'm gonna I'm going to give
somebody my data and now I'm going to
have to answer questions about that uh
the mechanisms of sharing are new and
they're not the way we've worked
traditionally
uh metrics for evaluating products that
you share data software for example are
underdeveloped and so it's hard to be
able to measure the that that you share
that and somebody's using it uh
intellectual property laws can hurt
sharing uh commercial entities can
profit from restricting access to
something so that they can charge more
for it and finally nonprofit scientific
societies are dependent often on Journal
subscription fees um and so they need
more funding than they actually uh cost
to do some of their work because it
supports other things that they do and
other work that they
do so um if we go into research software
then
specifically we care about research
software for a few different reasons um
one of them potentially is funding uh a
couple of things that I've looked at in
the past uh was 20% of NSF projects over
an 11year period topically discussed
software in their abstracts about $10
billion
uh Department of energy had an exoscale
Computing program that was about $6
billion um that just ended and that had
about four billion that was invested in
research software and just within NIH in
one particular year um it would I could
find $300 million of projects that
included software development as part of
their
projects uh we can also look at papers
and we can see that software intensive
projects are a majority of those that
are written about today and the most
cited papers are either methods papers
or software papers and and software is
generally an implementation of a
method and then finally we can just ask
researchers and we've done two different
surveys in the UK and the US and we've
found that over 90% of researchers use
research software about two-thirds
couldn't do their research without it
and about 50% are actually developing
software as part of their
research so um so that's about research
software but research software itself
actually plays a bunch of different
roles
and so you can think of research
software sometimes as a component of an
instrument sometimes you can think about
it as the instrument
itself uh sometimes it's the tool that
analyzes research
data sometimes it's a different tool
that is presenting research
results uh sometimes it's the glue that
assembles or integrates a bunch of
components into a working
hole sometimes it's the infrastructure
or the underlying tool in which you're
actually doing your work um and one
other piece is that did often is
facilitating um research oriented
collaborations it's it has this uh this
facilitation role as
well if we think then about where we
would like to be in terms of research
and how research software fits into it
we would I believe at least that we'd
like to have all research software that
can be open actually is
open we'd like all research software to
be high quality and
robust we'd like all research soft to be
findable accessible usable and actually
used by others for their own research
and that it should be cited when it is
used so that people that develop it
actually get
credit that all these contributors are
recognized for their work and they have
good career
paths that all research software is
sustained and continues to work as long
as it's
useful and that all research is
reproducible all of these have overlaps
in terms of incentives and policies and
they all start with the recognition of
research
software so so one point that is a a
problem that I want to bring up is
software collapse um the fact that
software does collapse and this is the
fact that software will stop working
eventually if it's not actively
maintained right you have if you have
data that data can stick around forever
you may have to worry about where it's
stored and it's format but the data
itself as a string of bits are going to
be okay uh software as a string of bits
that somebody can turn into text and
read may be fine but it actually won't
keep
working and that's because computational
science and data science software Stacks
um have a particular
structure and underneath them they have
non-scientific infrastructure things
like operating systems and compilers and
support code and user interfaces above
that is a scientific infrastructure like
libraries and utilities that are often
uh aimed at research across C
disciplines on top of that is discipline
specific software like tools and
libraries that Implement disciplinary
methods and models and then on top of
that is the Project Specific software
that's developed by particular
researchers and often and that's the
software that does a computation or a
data analysis using building blocks from
the lower levels it's often in the form
of scripts and workflows and notebooks
and small special purpose libraries un
utilities and the problem is because we
have the stack we have soft that's
building and depending on the software
on all layers below it and any change
below may cause the software to stop
working and so you can imagine this just
in the in the the most straightforward
case that you're uh you have an app on
your phone and the uh and the phone OS
changes and the app is no longer being
maintained and no longer works with that
with a new OS but it it carries across
scientific software and in many many
more cases and many many more
ways so we have have some challenges
then one of them is that research
software is developed and used for the
purpose of research to to generate
process analyze results within the
scholarly process it's increasingly
essential within the overall research
process but the challenges then include
the fact that software will collapse if
it's not maintained um software bugs are
found and so new features are needed and
new platforms arise all three of those
things uh the software development and
maintenance to deal with these is human
intent we do not have any method to
automate these at this point somebody
actually has to do this
work and then there's challenges on The
Human Side as well and as I said before
much of the research software is
developed by researchers these
researchers often know their disciplines
incredibly well but they don't often
know software best
practices and the researchers are not
rewarded for software development and
maintenance in
Academia and finally we are missing a
lot of people uh the software developers
don't match the diversity of our overall
Society or of our user communities and
so we leave out large numbers of people
that could be
contributing so having said all that I
want to just Define software
sustainability as the fact that the
software actually does endure um and the
way you can think about this is is the
software going to continue to be
available in the future on new platforms
meeting new
needs and this can only be measured in
hindsight if we want to try to say is
software sustainable we really can't we
can predict whether it will be or not we
can say it has been
sustained um again software development
maintenance requires active human effort
and human effort is kind of like money
but not exactly um so we can have
projects that maintain software that are
based entirely on human effort and we
often call those Community open source
projects we can have projects that are
entirely based on salary to create the
human effort that leads to the software
being maintained and that's what happens
with commercial software or with Grant
funded
projects but when we try to bring these
two together this is difficult because
uh effort isn't exactly money and people
aren't purely rational and if you have a
project where some people are being paid
to work on the project and other people
are being asked to contribute to it on a
voluntary basis that may or may not work
depending on how people are aligned and
and why they're thinking about
volunteering and what their volunteering
is worth to them
so uh just to to put this into some some
short words um about this research
software sustainability then is the
process of developing and maintaining
software that continues to meet its
purpose over time which includes
software adds new capabilities is needed
by its users responds to bugs and other
problems that are discovered and is
ported to work with new versions of the
underlying layers including software as
well as new
hardware some potential solutions to
this then are
to do things that reduce the amount of
work that's needed to sustain the
software do things that increase the
amount of resources that can be brought
to bear on sustaining the
software or do things that do both to
reduce the amount of work that's needed
and and increase the available
resources all three of these are are
valid paths that we can
use if we are thinking about reducing
the amount of work that's needed um
things that we can do include training
to developers which includes finding or
developing training material and the
carpentries is a great way to get
started with this with discipline
specific material and language specific
material available to help people do a
better job of writing software so it
needs less work in being
maintained uh we can use best practices
uh which involve uh finding or
developing those best practices
initially and again through the car
through the carpentry software carpentry
has some of these best practices and
there are also are
incubators like in earth science esip
the earth science information Partners
Apache more generally that can help
projects um develop best practices and
use them within those
projects if we're thinking about
increasing resources we can create
incentives so that people want to work
on the software so that we get more
human resources working on it we can
think about citations that help people
that are in their existing career path
um and I'm going to talk about that as
one of three topics that'll be coming up
just shortly we can think about
adjusting career paths so that they
better reward software work and we can
think about new career paths and new
career paths is going to be a second
thing I'll talk about
shortly uh we can also think about how
we increase funding by making the role
of software and research clear to
research funders like NIH NSF doe Etc
and then clearly making the case for
them to increase funding for new
software and to provide funding for
software maintenance uh you may have
seen that NIH actually has two new
programs that should be coming out
shortly for these two purposes and these
have happened because we as a community
have been talking to NIH for long enough
and they've realized that there was a
gap in their funding and they've created
mechanisms to address that
again um you can also seek institutional
resources and so if the software that
you're working on is considered
sufficiently important to your
institution either operation Al that it
lets it do things or reputationally that
it builds the reputation of that
institution then somebody at your
institution may be willing to commit
some resources to help keep that
Software
System um and then finally in this area
of reducing work and bringing in new
resources we can encourage
collaboration uh and so if we can use
the work of others rather than
reimplementing a function or package
that reduces what a team or its
developers needs to do themselves um and
if you are working with some somebody
else they may actually then also
contribute to your
software if you use somebody else's
software you could contribute to
maintaining it so that could then lead
to to less work that needs to be done um
but for these things to work the
software has to be designed from the
beginning to be modular and reusable and
it also has to be clearly documented and
explained to potential users even those
who are in fields other than developers
so this is really one of the big
challenges is is thinking about all
possible use cases when you start
building software that just particularly
focused on your own use
case um the team then also has to put a
lot of effort into engaging and working
with the potential user and contributor
Community right putting software onto
GitHub isn't going to do this you
actually have to put in active
work so a way of thinking about this is
that if you can make the software
findable accessible interoperable and
reusable that will go um towards
actually encouraging collaboration and
that is going to be the third thing that
I'll talk about and as we go forward
okay so having said that um let's get
into the the first one uh software
citation and I'm also going to talk a
little bit about the journal open source
software in this um I'll say that I'm
these three things I'm going to talk
about all of them are fairly high level
in some ways they're they're a little
bit of a a view of work that's been
happening and what's happened fairly
recently and I'm happy to talk about any
of these in more detail either through
questions or through email later
on so in 2015 uh and through 2016 we
started a software citation working
group under an organization called Force
11 uh Force 11 stands for the future
research communication e scholarship and
it started in
2011 uh Aran Smith and Kyle neier and I
c-ran this group and what we did was to
document the differences between
software and data because there was Data
citation already happening uh and then
to Define software citation challenges
um and we did that in two different uh
two different ways and then we set uh
out and worked with the community to
develop a set of software citation
principles and then publish those
principles and those principles are um
are six um importance which says that
the software should be considered a
legitimate and citable product of
research credit and attribution saying
that the purpose of software citation is
to facilitate giving scholarly credit
and and attribution to all contributors
unique identification saying that uh
purpose of software citation is to to
include a method for identification of
the specific software that was
used persistence that the uh citation to
the software should make sense even if
the software itself no longer exists
accessibility that the citation should
facilitate access to the software and
specificity that the citation should
facilitate identification of an access
to the specific version of the software
that was
TR so we came up with these these
principles we published them we talked
about them a lot we worked with
different communities about them and and
we finished our group and then we
started a implementation working group
um and in this case I was working with
Neil chuong and Martin Fenner to do this
and what we thought we were going to do
was to to write out a small amount of
detail that was needed to actually
Implement these principles to coordinate
people that were interested in working
on this and to work with different
communities to actually Implement them
we quickly realized that that small
amount of detail wasn't at all small
were making scattered progress but it
wasn't really being coordinated and that
there were underlying challenges that
weren't being addressed and so we wrote
a uh paper about this on inflation
implementation challenges uh to identify
those challenges and and help people
figure out what they could work on and
the technical challenges include the
complexity of software types and
identifiers for software and where
metadata is stored and the Social
Challenges include the fact that we
needed groups to work on implementation
in different contexts and then to come
together and run Pilots to establish
Norms so this implementation group oh
I'm sorry and this should actually say
2023 on the top not 2017 this group has
ended um so what we did though was to to
start Task forces and we started a
guidance task force that published
guidance for paper authors who wanted to
site software and for software
developers who wanted to make their
software
citable we had a metadata task force um
that was following a project called code
meta and code meta was aiming to
understand metadata for software more
widely than just in citation but
including in citation uh code meta built
a crosswalk of existing metadata
standards and then developed a standard
to describe software based on those
crosswalks and so what this task force
did was to to work with that code meta
group to update its standard and then to
describe everything in that standard
using schema.org properties and then to
work to move code met into a community
group that is on top of schema.org as
opposed to it being something separate
and to create a governance uh body for
for future changes to be able to be
made we created a software Registries
task force that developed the best
practice best practices document on how
software Registries and software
repositories should operate um so these
are the places that store software or
that register software and at least give
identifiers even if they don't archive
it and this community then turned into
something now that's called cyod which
is a Consortium of scientific software
Registries and repositories which meets
monthly and and talks about different
issues we had a journals task force
which worked with a bunch of Publishers
to provide generic guidelines for the
journals and conferences than to provide
to their authors uh with the idea that
these um Publishers would provide
specific guidelines that would be
matched to a community and the examples
that would fit into that community
uh we published this work and we worked
with a industry publishing group called
chorus to track which Publishers had
which Pol which uh
policies um and we also have just
finished some work on publication
processing which is basically looking at
once you as an author give citation
information to a publisher how does that
actually get handled internally and how
does it eventually get to an index so
that you can count when somebody sites
your software or when you've cited
somebody else's software or data um so
we found some problems in that process
and wrote a paper uh about
that um we finally also considered an
institutions task force thinking about
institutions as the places where people
work like universities or Labs uh with
the idea that we wanted to affect
policies and practices and think about
how those policies and practices
encourage citation and how they use
citation information and hiring and
promotion the idea was that we were
going to collect and share examples and
help form Community but we had
insufficient interest from the force1
working group members so we didn't do
this um I will say that under um
research data Alliance RDA and the
research software Alliance Risa we have
started a group called Pro for RS uh
research performing organization
policies around research software and we
are working on this now under that joint
group even though this didn't happen in
this in this software citation mation
working
group so so that's what we did and we
then kind of got to a question which was
what else would make sense to do and who
could do it and we had a workshop in
2022 to address this and wrote a report
about kind of where we saw the state of
this after five years of work and this
working group then ended in
2023 um but there are certainly members
of the community that are still
interested in discussions and we're
currently writing up a blog post to have
uh to suggest topics and venues for that
continued discussion to happen Okay so
that's sare citation um I also want to
talk about Journal of Open Source
software just really briefly as part of
this um so so Joss is a developer
friendly journal for research software
packages our goal is that if you have
licensed your code and if good
documentation it should take less than
an hour to prepare and submit your paper
and everything about JS is open the
submitted and published paper itself is
open the code is open the reviews and
the process are completely open um and
the code for the journal itself is open
and so this code has been used for the
Journal of Open Source education and for
the proceedings of the julon conferences
as
well uh JS papers are archived they get
dois and they are increasingly indexed
although we always have challenges with
particular uh commercial
indexers uh first paper was submitted in
2016 uh about a year later we were up to
about 111 accepted
papers couple of days ago we're up to
about 2,300 accepted papers uh you can
see that we are uh basically gradually
increasing we went uh up fairly quickly
until covid which is that kind of Gap in
the Middle where we shut down things for
a couple of months um and then we more
or less have leveled off with a slow
increase since then we're at about 1.1
papers per day and and slowly
increasing uh we had one editorinchief
and 11 editors at the beginning and
today we have one editor-in Chief six
associat or editors and 84 editors as
well as 41 editors that have completed
terms and have uh have decided not to
renew after one or two
terms so I want to just talk very very
briefly about Jos as a community because
I think this is something where or you
can think about software citation on one
side you can think about a journal on
the other side that's publishing
software papers and you might say that
those are not the same why do we need
both of those um and and one thing I
think that's important is is Joss is a
community and you can think about
communities having culture that changes
based on rules and incentives and so
js's practices really have influenced
reviewers and developers in terms of
what's good and what's minimally
acceptable and this is similar to what R
open S has done in the r community and
this is also something that you could
not do just through sighting software
you need a community to come together to
do this um so in Jos the minimum
criteria for successful review has
changed over time as Community best
practices develop so our minimum for
packaging and for testing and continuous
integration and documentation has
changed from where it was s years
ago um Jos is also applying open sof
open source software practices to
reviews like openness and collaboration
so the process is completely different
from a from a review that you would have
in another Journal where you submit
something and then you hear back some
some negative results and some feedback
um the the this JS review is is very
Interactive um Jos is also then
providing these rules and at a high
level it's trying to nudge incentives
you we're trying to get to the point
where accepted software is equal to an
accepted paper again citation of the
software directly is One path uh Joss is
another path um and if software was
cited directly the JS papers themselves
would no longer be needed but the JS
reviews in the JS Community would still
have great
value okay so uh let me go on into the
second research software engineers um
again as I've said before research
software often comes from research and
this has happened really from the
beginning of computing uh again as far
as I can tell software as a concept
started appearing around 1948 research
software started appearing a couple of
years later um software engineering
started in the late 1960s mostly applied
to operational software like operating
systems or NASA flights or things like
that um the idea of using good software
practices in research software is
something that is relatively new and
most researchers generally don't know
what good practices they should be
following the software Engineers who
know good research practices for
software um generally don't understand
research and we do get students in
postdocs who initially don't know good
software practices and don't stick
around but some of them do and often
they will join the staff of an
institution and sometimes this is
unofficial they just stay a postto for a
really long time um but sometimes there
may be career paths develop and they
become permanent members of the staff
and we do get to a point where we
eventually do have some at least staff
members who understand research and how
it works really well and also understand
software engineering pretty
well so we can think about uh staff and
faculty and people in universities and
research institutions often in two
different ways as the as craft people
and Scholars and a scholar we can Define
as a researcher who's driven to
understand things to their fullest
capability um they find intellectually
demanding problems they do curiosity
driven work and they work on a topic
until they understand it and they pass
on that understanding often through
teaching we can also think about craft
people as people who are driven to to
create and and leave behind artifacts
that explain their efforts in the field
uh these are people that feel pain when
they make something that's more fragile
or ugly than they think it should
uh they prefer to make things that
explain themselves rather than teach
people about them and they this kind of
work requires patience and pride and
doing a job
well um scientific software needs people
who do both of these and I just want to
point out I'm taking this from a blog
post that's from 2012 so this is this is
how long some of this discussion has
been going
on um you can think then of a research
software engineer as uh somebody who's
sitting in a space where a software
engineer engineering is one access and
research is another and there are people
who are great researchers and there are
people who are great software Engineers
but don't really know much about the
other there are actually a number of
people and have been over a fairly long
period who are researcher developers um
they really know research quite well and
they know a good deal about software
development as well what we're trying to
add here are research software Engineers
who are more in the middle more uh
really understanding both to a pretty
good level and and this is somewhere as
a as a fuzzy set in the middle it's not
really one
point okay so in 2012 uh in the UK there
was a workshop that was called
collaborations workshop and what that
Workshop um did was it was a it was a
very interactive workshop and one of the
breakout groups um talked about research
software engineering and uh and they
decided that there were a lot of people
that were already doing such work but
they didn't have any common title and
they did some work and they discovered
there were 194 different jobs that were
open in the UK at that point in Academia
that all seemed to be research software
engineering and in some way or another
and so they decided research software
engineer was a title that they could all
live with and that it would help them
unify uh they realized that there was no
Community for all these people and so
they started up an association which
I'll talk about uh in the next slide
having turned into multiple associations
and
societies and they realized that this
was into profession and so they started
defining career paths and thinking about
a structure that would turn this into a
profession so in the 11 years since then
we have this movement in term that was
born in the UK and in 2013 the UK rsse
Association formed with 50 members this
is now a a society that has 700 uh dues
paying members and about 5,300 people
overall there are also other sociey or
associations that have formed in Belgium
and Germany and the Netherlands the
Nordic countries and Australia New
Zealand um as well as here in the US and
the uh us um organization has about 2300
members across universities National
Labs and Industry
today there are also new associations
that are trying to form in Africa and in
Asia uh Africa mostly LED from South
Africa and Asia mostly LED from India
but both with goals Beyond those
countries specifically
and the idea of having all these
different associations around the world
is that they can work on local issues um
collectively within their Association
and they can also coordinate across
associations right so how we do hiring
and promotion in the US is quite
different than how it's done in India
for example um but we can talk to each
other and share
lessons it also turns out and this is
something that was surprising to most
people in this rsse
community that in France uh kind of
hidden from our view was a something
called devlog which was a national
network of research software Engineers
that was created in 2011 a year before
the UK group started um and it was
created from 15 local networks some of
which had started long before
2011 um and so the thing that turned out
to be interesting was that all of these
International groups that I talked about
on the previous slide um all talk to
each other in English um English isn't
necessarily the language that they do
all their work in but often it is and it
is the language they communicate
externally in uh the French group speaks
in French and they communicate
externally primarily in French and
that's the reason that we actually were
missing the connection between these two
and so there's a few of us now that are
trying to figure out how do we actually
bring these two things together so that
we can again learn more from each
other okay the last of the three topics
that I want to talk about then is is
fair for research
software um I'm hopeful that most people
that are are listening are familiar with
the fair principles for scientific data
management and stewardship um it's worth
pointing out that that says data in the
in the title and when we think about the
fair principles I prefer to call these
the fair data
principles uh there are a set of
principles to ensure that data are
shared in a way that enables and
enhances reuse by humans and machines
and um I'm not going to go through this
in in great detail again I'm hoping that
people are aware of this but I'll just
say that the principles um include
activities uh or sub principles
objectives to make the data findable um
to make it accessible so once you found
it you can actually get to it to make it
interoperable meaning that you can use
it with other data and to make it
reusable meaning that you can uh just
simply use it again for maybe for the
same purpose or maybe for a different
purpose
so um in 2016 this paper came out based
on work that had started really in 2014
and um partly because there was a need
for this and partly because fair was a
pretty clever acronym this is caught on
and there are a number of funders and
Publishers and institutions that are now
pushing fair and making sure that data
is is made
Fair we can also think about fair for
non-data objects and U as as I said um
or as I kind of meant to say uh the fair
principles at a high level uh say that
they're intended to apply to all
research objects both those that are
used in research and those that are
research outputs but the text of the
principles often includes metadata as
part of the statement of a principle and
this is shorthand for metadata and data
it's not uh research outputs or research
objects it's specifically metadata and
data um the principles are applied
through data set creators and rep
repositories and often they're
collectively responsible for creating
annotating indexing preserving and
sharing the data sets in their
metadata this assumes that there are
separate and sequential Creator and
publisher roles somebody creates the
data set they give it to the repository
the repository does some stuff with
it if we think about objects that are
not data um they can often be stored as
data but they're not just data uh and
these high Lev goals of findable
accessible inter operable and reusable
are really pretty similar but the
details about them and how they're
implemented depend on what the objects
are and they depend in particular on how
the objects are created and used how and
where the objects are stored and shared
and how and where metadata is stored in
indexed and it won't be probably
surprising to you that my point is going
to be that this is different for
software than it is for data in in all
of these three
questions and so this then leads to the
fact that we believed work is needed or
was needed to Define and Implement and
adopt principles to other objects that
are not straightforward
data um this isn't just the opinion of
of a group that I'm going to talk about
um this is uh something that has come
out of the fair practice task force in
EOS the European
open science Cloud if I'm getting that
right uh as well as the French National
Committee for open Sciences free
software an open source project group um
both of these uh groups had
recommendations and both of these
included recommendations that said that
software is not data and different kinds
of work will be needed to make it
fair um and so there's a group that I'm
going to talk about that focused on the
adaptation and Adoption of the fair
principles to research
software okay so again software isn't
data in some of the some of the reasons
for this is that uh it's not just data
it can be stored as data but if you
treat it as data you're missing out on a
lot uh software is executable while data
isn't uh data provides evidence software
provides a tool uh software is a
creative work scientific data typically
are facts and observations and this
leads to different uh legal treatments
of them they have different licensing
and different copyright practices around
them uh I'll just mention just as an
example uh Creative Commons licenses are
typically used for data open- source
initiative licenses are typically used
for software both OSI and creative
common say don't use Creative Commons
licenses for software for example
because they're not designed for that
and they don't work well for
that um software has a different kind of
of bit rot uh than data I talked about
that earlier software collapse is
different than than the bit rot that
happens with data which is more related
to the
storage the lifetime of software is
generally not as long as that of data
and software is often more Dynamic than
data um and finally for open source
software in particular we don't have
this Creator publisher sequence that is
typical for data um and there's often no
natural publisher so if you think about
software that's being developed on
GitHub uh people are using it while it's
being developed they're not waiting for
it to finish uh in some sense it may
never be finished it always maybe in the
process of being developed and there's
no archival repository that people need
to put their their software into for
people to use it right they're using
this the social coding platform GitHub
or they're using a package management
system or something
else so uh fair for research software
then was a working group that defined
consensus Fair principles for research
software it was led by a group of of
nine of us um it worked under three
different organizations I've mentioned
all three of these before but just again
briefly Force 11 which often focuses on
Research communication research data
Alliance that focuses on data and
research software Alliance that focuses
on
software uh what we did was to create a
definition of research software being
research software is source code files
algorithms scripts computational
workflows and executables they were
created during the research process or
for a research
purpose there's also additional software
components like operating systems and
libraries and dependencies and other
things that're be used for research but
they weren't created during or with a
research intent and we think that those
should be considered software in
research and not research software um
but this differentiation varies between
disciplines so just as an example of
this if you are working on uh brain
Imaging the operating system of the
computer that you're using is almost
certainly research in software for you
it's not research software but if you're
working on operating system research and
computer science then the operating
system that could be exactly the same
operating system is research software
for you so it's a little bit
tricky so the principles that we came up
with then which were published in 2020
uh under RDA um are that well actually
so so I should say um I'm I'm not going
to go through all this in great detail
again but I will say that the things
that are in italics here are the ones
that are significantly different from
the fair data principles um they're also
other differences we start off with
talking about software rather than than
data but that's small um so the main
differences are that in in findable um
there's differences because different
components of software have different
identifiers related to different levels
of granularity from a package to a file
to a line of code to a release U for
example and different versions of
software have different identifiers and
and the issue here is that software
almost always has multiple versions or
data sometimes does but data often
doesn't um in terms of accessibility
these principles are almost the same I'm
not going to say anything else about
that uh in terms of interoperability uh
we actually had to Define what
interoperability means for software
because it seemed like it was different
than for data and so what we defined was
that software interoperability meant how
software worked with other software and
explicitly through exchanging data and
metadata or interaction through apis
they were described through
standards and reusable again was was
fairly different than reusable for data
in that software has to be first usable
that it can be executed because you can
think about either reading or executing
software as two different ways of using
it um and and reusable means that once
you understand it you can modify it and
build on it and incorporate it into
other software and so this means that
this software then has to be scoped in a
way that makes it clear how it is
related to other software
okay so we published these principles uh
about a year and a half ago now and we
turned uh governance including
interpretation and future revisions over
to the RDA software source code interest
group um if you've looked at the fair
data principles you may have realized
that if you have questions there's not
really anyone you can ask they didn't
Define that and they didn't Define a
method for how they could be revised in
the future and we wanted to to learn
from that and to to do those things so
the RDA uh software source code interest
group will be uh this summer looking at
the principles two years later and
trying to see if anything needs to be
changed or if the principles have proven
to be useful as
written we did a survey of adoption
guidelines kind of what organizations
were looking at um as well as what those
organizations actually were doing and we
published uh two documents about those
two different
things um the fair for research software
actually tends to expose some ecosystem
gaps particularly related to metadata
And archiving inversions and some of
this overlaps with the software citation
discussion I had before uh again as I as
I said earlier the Creator and publisher
sequence doesn't really apply to fair to
software really uh there's questions
about where metadata should be stored
for software should it be stored in a
code repository for open source software
if so what do you do for closed Source
software maybe it's an archival reposit
like zenodo or something like that maybe
it's in a registry we don't have a good
answer um how software is actually
archived is another good question
because gitlab giab sorry GitHub and
gitlab have the idea of repository they
use that name but they don't use it in
the same way as a data repository it's
not an archival place that you deposit
something and somebody takes care of it
for a long
time um
so this also isn't clear there's a an
activity called software Heritage that
has started up a couple of years ago
that may be the answer to this and
software Heritage uh his goal is
effectively to be the internet archive
for software so where the internet
archive is uh crawling URLs and trying
to Archive them as often as they can
software Heritage is crawling GitHub and
gitlab and other open source places and
trying to create an archival version of
them uh we also have the fact that
different use cases for soft W can need
a specific version of the software or
the latest version of the software or in
some cases all versions of the
software
and while this is true with data it's
equally true with software that having
Fair software doesn't actually say
anything about the software being high
quality it doesn't say anything about
the software being correct doesn't say
anything about how you use the software
for reproducibility it doesn't even say
the software has to be open um so
there's a lot of stuff that we would
like to do Beyond fair to make software
better okay so having gone through those
three things I want to wrap up just by
giving a little bit more information
about the research software Alliance
because I've mentioned it a couple of
times and it's really a way of trying to
bring some of these things
together um the research software
Alliance has the vision of research
software and those who develop and
maintain it being recognized and valued
as fundamental and vital to research
worldwide its mission is to advance the
research software ecosystem by
collaborating with key influence ERS and
decision makers it was founded in 2019
it's a fiscally sponsored um
organization under code for Science and
society and so Risa has been involved in
co-developing these the fair principles
that I mentioned before uh looking at
diversity equity and inclusion best
practices via a workshop U mapping the
international research software
landscape uh bringing together Global
Research software funders to set the
agenda for sustainable research software
um this l to the adore declaration uh
the Amsterdam Declaration on funding
research software sustainability which
I'll talk about slightly more in the
next slide and then collaborating on
ongoing task forces on issues that are
affecting the Global Research software
Community if you're interested in
participating in Risa you can sign up
from the website to receive the
newsletter uh join this Flack we have a
funding calls database that tries to
keep track of all funding calls where
research software can be supported and
again you can join multiple task forces
as
well uh I mentioned this adore
declaration which came out of a a
workshop in Amsterdam in the end of 2022
uh when Risa formed research software
funding was one of the immediate topics
that was of interest to a lot of the
people um and we had a bunch of funders
that came and they wanted to exchange
experience and identify ways to have a
greater impact on Research software and
this includes NH for
example uh we started a funders forum
and in that funders Forum we had disc
discussions as well as other discussions
happening elsewhere that were all
brought together to create this Workshop
in Amsterdam November of 2022 and we had
brought 45 different funding
organizations together to talk about
things
there we gave them an initial draft
declaration about research software and
they provided a lot of feedback um this
led to a version one which is available
on adore. software as a website and we
created a stewardship group that
includes represent of the signatories um
supported by a Secretariat that's
responsible for overseeing and promoting
an endorion an endorsement process which
we started last
fall so just to then wrap up uh all of
this today research software is
increasingly important to
research citation is the accepted
mechanism for scholarly Credit in
Academia and software citation is
starting to be accepted with uptake from
researchers Publishers Librarians and
others
software papers are partially a
placeholder for software citation where
that citation is not uh directly
accepted yet um but software papers also
have an important Community
function research software Engineers is
something that is recently recognized as
a role but has a much longer history and
we're now building community and making
a case for formal career paths the fair
data principles set out a good goal
initially to share data to enable and
enhance reuse but we realized that work
was needed to apply this to research
soft for everyone not just for research
software Engineers but for for faculty
for postdocs for
everyone uh you can promote the adore.
software
declaration uh you can think about the
fact that open science and open software
and and fair for research software and
citation and research software
engineering and Rea are all open
communities and you can join any of them
and try to get involved and and try to
contribute and if nothing else at least
learn and overall what I'd ask is try to
raise awareness of research software as
a key element of research and understand
that research software is its own thing
it's it's not business software it has
different goals incentives methods
practices Workforce education and all of
these have work that's needed to to get
here so with that I will wrap up I'll
just thank a number of people that were
involved in different parts of
this um yeah I'm not going to go through
this in detail but this is in the slides
and I'll I'll stop here and and see what
kinds of questions we have and thank
everybody for listening Dan thank you so
much I actually have I personally have a
lot of questions um thank you so much
for giving this the Fantastic rundown um
I know that uh you had been doing a lot
of work in this space for some time and
it's really nice to see uh kind of the
sum total of all these activities one of
the things which I personally like to
tell people is that the fair acronym
actually has a silent e at the end and I
sort of I do this somewhat jokingly but
that silent E stands for Education
that's the data and in this case maybe
software actually have a role in
education and I'm you don't have to
adopt the silent E if you don't want to
but I was curious if you had any
comments about the role of software
sharing openness Etc um and its place in
educating the next generation of
software
developers um I you know it's it's
interesting I actually I haven't heard
uh that before and I I appreciate what
you're saying I haven't really thought
about that too much I I guess I've
really been mostly thinking about the
research side of things and research um
as a part of education but not education
that's happening outside of research so
I think that what you're saying makes
complete sense to me but I I haven't
thought about it enough to really have
anything useful to say I don't think
well I hope that in some of your um in
your interactions with some of the
communities that you're working with
with the many communities which you're
working with that maybe you could
introduce this idea and I'm not trying
to assur the fair acronym or the the
purposes thereof but um I think that
there's that's an important opportunity
um because you know people can look at
this code they can learn from it they
can be developing whatever the next
algorithms happen to be based on that
code and uh also just the practices I
mean you list many best practices and
obviously sharing and and fairness
itself is a best practice and educating
the community about what those best
practices are is probably important um
yeah no that that definitely makes sense
and I I I should say I'm a co-author on
a a paper that's just got submitted to h
plus uh computational bio last week or a
week before um that's also suggesting
some other additions to fair and so I
there's almost a cottage industry and
talking about what else Fair needs to
have and so education is is a good one
to I I was impressed with the the the
work you described um at in the UK where
they identified like 194 job titles that
uh it was all possible to coales them
into uh research software engineers and
I was kind of like thinking as you were
describing that about you know usually
the kind of software engineer software
developers the hackers they're usually
these kind of Lone Wolf characters who
really actually don't like to work very
often with other people that they're uh
kind of like on their own I'm curious if
you've run into any um you know it's
like for example what colleague told me
once that when he was in college he
founded an anarchists club which I
thought was kind of there's an irony
there yeah is there have you seen any
sort of sociological problems yeah you
so it's um it's interesting that you say
that I mean I think that that definitely
is a a perception I'm not sure that it's
uh any more valid in the software
Community than it is in any other
community um so here at NCSA we have
about 40 rsc's in in one team nice um
and just in terms of title we changed
the title to RSC about two years ago it
had been research software developer for
a long time before that um and so we we
wanted to kind of join the community and
and use a standard title um but
everybody that we have is working in
projects collectively with uh with
researchers um we're either building
Technologies that we think are important
and then working with different
researchers often multiple researchers
that want to use them or working with
specific researchers who want a specific
technology for their own research um so
I think research software engineering is
actually is an incredibly collaborative
activity um that that needs to work with
the researchers and I I don't think the
stereotype about the software developers
kind of being off on their own and and
not wanting to talk to people
really holds in the research on
engineering community um any more than
it would for for faculty or or graduate
students or others and yeah sure there
are going to be some people that are
like that but that's not the majority
well I I'm sure that's just a a you know
Hollywood stereotype I hope but uh it
sounds like there is a very very rich
Community um that's built you know not
only in in Europe but developed here in
the in the US as well and elsewhere
around the world for people to
communicate their their best practices
their code and to publish them in
journals uh like JS and various other um
venues and so uh thank you so much for
sharing stuff and uh Dan Catz uh thank
you so much we really appreciate your
you're taking time to share this work
with us and uh we look forward to uh
having further chats in the future and
to everybody who's watching us uh thank
you so much for joining us we'll see you
next time he thanks very much thank you
Dan